über und jetzt mag es an die waffen
innerhalb von zwei minuten
karanovic ersetzt und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video und
heute die bedeute haben wir das hier
dabei was ist das das ist die sache die
in letzter zeit auf youtube laufen
untergegangen ist und zwar magischer
sand und was machen wir damit heute habt
ihr schon im titel gesehen ich und max
herm aktuelle flotte werden heute
youtuber aus diesen magischen blauen
sand nachbauen
mit einer kamera das folgendermaßen
leute ich hab euch gerade eben auf
twitter gebeten
das war ein richtig sinnloser twitter
post schreibt einfach irgendwo ein
youtube-user youtube ist euch nachbarn
okay ich hoffe irgendwann trotzdem
sinnvoll geantwortet denn wir werden
jetzt eure twitter vorschläge nehmen wir
gehen jetzt den tweet durst und arbeiten
die vorschläge von oben nach unten ab
als allererstes muss natürlich mal hier
erst mal gucken was das ist wir waren
heute im elsass leute und haben uns
wieder neues spielzeug für videos
geguckt sieht jetzt schon richtig geil
aus das sind so die diva als kind haben
wollte
da ist er wie geil das aussieht alter
schwede
die sie das hat nämlich ein maßstab
du kannst tatsächlich einfach
zusammenrücken krasser das ist wie knete
ja das ist richtig das gefühl den finger
das eigentlich gar nicht so teuer dass
halbe kilo was wir da an
okay ein neubau gekostet ist es immer
noch ein geheimnis kilo sand für neun
euro hoch das gibt es an jedem
handelsüblichen strand umsonst nennt man
wenn man das so fest zusammendrückt das
dann auch zu hart ist alter schwede
leute dann macht mal wieder auf wir
werden jetzt versuchen und youtube aus
sand nachzubauen die uns vorgeschlagen
habe am ende dürft ihr auch entscheiden
wer am besten gebaut hat wir haben das
bisher noch gar nicht ausprobiert ob das
überhaupt hinhauen kann aber okay leute
ich geh jetzt auf twitter
hier ist man liegt so hier welche
youtube soll ich mal für euch kneten
okay willst du ready ich bin sobald ich
den namen gesagt habt staatlichen
countern von einer minute auf meinem
handy
innerhalb der 1 minute versuchen
irgendwas brauchbares zu bauen auch die
alles klappt dann die erste antworten
erste antwort und zwar was die zockt
schreibt bauten mich passt das land
damals schon kein dino einfach darum
gehen wer sieht er ihn mensch aus als ob
das hat der bastille zockte kräfte riss
ich weiß nicht aber du geht max
machtvoll staudamm den körper so so
flach zu bauen
zack zack zack zack jetzt kommst du
jetzt oder wie ich glaube es jetzt auf
youtube zeigt alte schwede sicherheit
nicht weit entfernt das menschlich aus
armen wir noch 15 sekunden
15 sekunden das macht ein basti zockt
auf jeweils wir müssen erstmal manager
eine minute ist so wenig zeitalter okay
leute also das hier ist jetzt unsere
handys beginn an sebastian was man kann
wirklich schwer differenzieren was der
ursprünglichen haus gebaut ist was
mensch hey hey verglich dazu also okay
das ist sebastians karriere
ich finde das ist ein pokémon ist aber
sebastian hat sich vertan schade dass
das sollten am computer sein glaube wir
brauchen mehr zeit ich würde sagen für
den nächsten youtube und 82 minuten ok
radierung geht an mich leute dass die
vier den kommentaren scheint kommt
einfach mal wird die erste runde
gewonnen max oder ich sebastian schreibt
bist du okay leute der zweite tweet
kommen von michael und sie sagt baut
klingt wie das denn ich weiß es selbst
wichtiger countdown startet 321 jetzt
juni was keiner für beide hat wusste ich
ja gar nicht
es ist so schwer wie diesen seiten
menschen nachzubauen alter schwede
dachte das lässt aber es hätte richtig
schwer aber der mets immer immer zwei
minuten zeit das hat man schon jetzt bei
den körper und problemen bekommen
lasst euch ja schon mal sehen ob du
nachher und noch lebst ok alles klar
dass menschen zu tode dafür sorgen dass
der mensch viel länger als 30 sekunden
aufdecker 5321 stopp okay max schaumburg
also dass mein klingeln wieder mal
mensch eine beinahe an oberkörper und
unterkörper den ohren und der körper
aber war am 8
super dann habe ich eine brille gewesen
zumindest damit versucht das war
ziemlich schwierig das war das ruhig
meinte details zu sperren dann aber
bitte meinen kleckern
also leute mein kleiner hat auf jeden
fall sehr was sie beide eine menge
beide treten für das studio geht euch
das mal hier der bericht zeigt dass
darum ist noch und das gymnasium und das
hier oben ist so die klänge an frisur
aber leute die entscheidungs bei euch
haben die kommentare bei die runde
gewonnen hat okay leute ich hab die
tweets durchgeschaut und die finale
entscheidung ist gefallen wir werden
eine person bauen die noch nie niemals
in irgend einem youtuber bauen wie hier
angenommen wurde weil sie einfach
körperlich total und verhilft die
leichteren idee freilich bemerken denn
wir bauen jetzt mag es an die waffen
innerhalb von zwei minuten
kaka wird jetzt katja leute welchem
körpermerkmal wirst du die meiste
aufmerksamkeit max welches kette subway
sein was bei diesem youtube besonders
hervor stach aber auch wieder richtig
fette stelzen über kinder nehmen
machen wieder nur zwei minuten wir
machen wieder nur zwei minuten dann
musste ich anhalten bedeutet es wird ein
film gehen irgendwie im körper
hinzubekommen wenn einfach mega fete war
ehrlich leute müssen es ja nix
okay das noch 45 sekunden hätte jetzt
sowieso passworte die spitze alltag
denker aus jetzt gab einen
schraubenschlüssel
er muss weg und federnd ok und stopp
stopp stopp stopp start so leute die
finale auswertung was unfair
die tipps zerfall das ist ein kriterium
das wie haltbar wie unfair halte die war
gerade eben noch ganz
das ist meine katja bist du benutzt
es ist ihr verband diese beiden
körpermerkmale waren gerade ihren
glücklichen tag der sehr genau so aus
wie der bisher auf einmal sich
entschieden zu zerfallen
dies beweise denn die kammer hat ja auch
da brauchst keine beweise
ok schauen uns mal den kopf an wir haben
hier perfekt dargestellt habe kommt hier
gibt's dann nach außen wieder islamiah
haare hat sie bisschen aus wie das wird
es mir du sack kauft wunderschön auch
ihre schlanken beine die wohlgeformter
trainierter körper
ich würde sagen leute note 1 dann kommen
wir mal für meine beine ich hatte am
anfang probiert so dass so ein bisschen
1 zurück und so weißt du dass du halt
ober und unterschenkel es hat nicht
funktioniert teil ihr wollt ihr einmal
hat nicht funktioniert was wir hier
aussieht ausgewählt aus dem fünften
stock strom herkommt wie hoch geschlagen
jetzt bin ich so ganz zufrieden hatte
ich aber ihr könnt sagen sie am besten
ob die leute das ist schön aus wie eine
banane leute das war unser experiment
einfach mal youtube mit magischen sand
nachzubauen
ich würde sagen wir haben ein bisschen
unterschätzt er fällt einfach mega
schnell aber
okay wer sich das gefallen hat lassen
like da und das lachen bei 2017 oder
schon ein bisschen 2017 sagt veit